RETO MEIER: What's more
fun than Pair Programming?
Asynchronous Remote Massive
Scale Pair Programming.
In 2011, I presented
an I/O session,
Pro Tips for Building
Context Aware Apps.
Those tips went
into a sample app
that targets Android Honeycomb
and supports Cupcake.
That's Android 1.6, if
you're keeping track.
That covered 98% of
active devices in 2011.
Today, it's less than 3.2%.
Clearly, it's time
to do an update.
I asked if you'd
like to watch me
go through the process of
updating the app and you said,
yes.
So, despite some skepticism--
FEMALE SPEAKER: You know they're
just trolling you, right?
Nobody wants to watch you
write code on YouTube.
RETO MEIER: I don't know.
There's like the Facebook
movie, "Silicon Valley,"
"CSI: Cyber," "Scorpion."
These are all really,
really popular.
And this is a lot like them.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This
is nothing like them.
MALE SPEAKER: Woah, wait, you
haven't been telling people
that this is like them, right?
Because this is
nothing like them.
This would be boring.
RETO MEIER: Strong skepticism.
I'm giving it a shot.
The result is pivotal.
It's a lot like cereal--
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's
not like that either.
RETO MEIER: Each episode
is part of a larger story.
Having an app
targeting an API that's
fallen off the sliding
scale of relevancy
is a great opportunity
to replace tricks, hacks,
and deprecated APIs with a
robust modern architecture.
That means integrating the
Android Support Library,
the Fused Location Provider, the
Job Scheduler, material design,
Enhanced Notifications, Android
Wear, and all the features
of Ice Cream Sandwich, Jelly
Bean, KitKat, Lollipop,
and Marshmallow.
And everything else I don't yet
realize needs to be updated.
You won't see much of
me, but imagine me here,
dressed neatly at a tidy
desk, with a warm cup of tea.
Definitely do not
picture me with my feet
up on a messy desk,
and absolutely not me
at home in my pajamas.
Picture me here,
in my happy place.
MALE SPEAKER: Reto,
we're going to need
you to clear out of here.
We've got another shoot.
Couldn't you do
this at your desk?
RETO MEIER: I'm Reto Meier.
Join me on the Android
Developers YouTube channel,
as I bring all that back to
the future, here in my office.
Welcome to Pivotal.
[MUSIC PLAYING]